0/3 here I have 3/0 which one of these
is equal to zero and which of them is
undefined well I'll tell you how I think
about it what I think about is this
fraction bar is really like a division
sign this is like zero divided by three
and when you divide something into
threes or thirds think about like maybe
like a pizza okay if you have a pizza
and you say hmm I want to divide this
into 3 equal slices okay but I'm gonna
have 0 thirds so I'm not gonna have one
part out of 3 or 2 parts out of 3 or 3
parts out of 3 I'm gonna have 0 parts
out of the 3 that it's divided into so
that means really you're gonna have 0
pizza right so that means that 0 thirds
is 0 so if you can remember if the
numerator 0 okay if the numerator 0 the
whole fraction will be equal to 0 ok now
if we go to number 2
we've got 3 divided by 0 so we can go
back to our pizza analogy and we could
say hmm we're gonna divide this pizza
into zeros zeros so even if I don't cut
this pizza at all it's still one
gigantic piece won't you agree so we
can't really divide it into zeros okay
so that means that this is undefined you
can't divide it into zeros this is
undefined sometimes written with this
symbol here or you could write the word
undefined now oftentimes this comes up
when students are studying you know
slopes and you're learning about in your
class how to find you know like the
angle of a line and basically when you
get a slope of 0 that just means that
it's a horizontal line it's not going up
it's not going down its horizontal has a
zero slope whereas an undefined slope is
actually a vertical line it's going up
and down like that so I hope this helped
me to understand how to work with
fractions that have a zero either in the
numerator or denominator
subscribe to the channel check out some
of my other videos on Mario's math tutor
and YouTube channel and I look forward
to seeing in the future videos